hi I'm Monica fields and this is good
life project so my guest today is rich
roll who owns the title of fittest men
in the world and he's the author of a
really good book called finding ultra
we're gonna kind of go into his journey
because this wasn't always his existence
so awesome me hanging out with you today
yeah thanks for having me it's great to
be here yeah so you are now according to
the ultimate resources the fittest guy
in the world
certain dubious resources right aka my
best friend um that ultra marathoner
extraordinary athlete and you've got
built a really fascinating life for
yourself but I want to take a step back
because this actually was not your life
and was not the way that you were living
in fact it was pretty close to the
opposite so before you sort of embrace
this complete commitment take me back to
what your life was like and what you
were doing
sure um well I guess my my life started
out quite good I was a I was an
excellent student in high school
loving parents that are still married
and kind of had all of my needs met and
ended up getting into all the colleges I
applied to and I was a swimmer in high
school and in college and you know had
achieved a certain level of proficiency
with that ended up going to Stanford
University and that's where things kind
of started to shift because I discovered
the wondrous effects of alcohol which
over the course of the next 15 years
sort of led to my personal decline and
took me to some pretty dark places so I
had a kind of protracted battle with
drug addiction and alcohol that really
kind of disconnected me from myself I
mean not only you know did I become
alienated from my friends and family and
unemployable and
and you know one step away from homeless
really just disconnected from who I was
as a person so from there was were the
people around you sort of aware of what
was going on or certainly you know my
family was very concerned had been
trying to help me and I had not kind of
hit my bottom yet and wasn't ready to
accept help and it got to the point
where you know my parents were like we
don't want to talk to you anymore
you know when you're ready to address
this problem you know are you can call
us anytime but until then like we don't
want to hear from you and my boss I was
I was a senior associate at a big
corporate law firm in Los Angeles and he
was ready to fire me he knew what was
going on everybody knew what was going
on but you know denial is a very
powerful human emotion and exceptionally
powerful in an active alcoholic so it
took some time before I was really ready
to grapple in a real way with this
problem of course I knew I was an
alcoholic but there's a there's a gap
between self-knowledge and taking action
to address the problem well I mean so
there was a little bit of a leap to you
go from Stanford to be a lawyer mm-hmm
and large law firm right
all the while sort of like living this
can almost double life yeah for sure
very secretive life I became very good
at lying and deceiving people about what
I was really doing and was able to kind
of keep it together for a while I mean I
was able to graduate from Stanford and I
was able to by the hair of my
chinny-chin-chin get into law school and
somehow you know to this day I look back
on that experience and wonder how the
heck I actually graduated from law
school but somehow I did and you know
was able to get a job so I was you know
I was able to kind of get get my life
together enough to put up a face that I
was a responsible member of society but
kind of pulling the curtain back if you
were to look at kind of how it was
actually really conducting myself it was
a very different picture and so when
you're in active
drug addict or alcoholic and you're
trying to navigate the world you have to
spin a lot of plates to kind of keep the
facade up and it's exhausting actually
yeah I mean for you was was the draw was
it something that you were escaping was
it or was it more of a chemical was a
genetic was it some blend of was there
something that you were self-medicating
for what was it that drew you into this
place um you know asked myself that
question a lot and I don't know that I
have the answer I mean I know that I'm a
drug addict and an alcoholic and why on
that way is kind of you know something
I'll probably continue to explore for
the rest of my life well nobody in my
immediate family is an alcoholic so I
can't say that I had a genetic
predisposition to it and of course I can
say well you know I was depressed about
this or whatever but I don't really find
that to be productive you know I know
that I am and I know what the solution
is for me you know I know how I got
sober and I know what I need to do to
stay sober and so sort of pondering the
that you know the wise kind of leads me
down a rabbit hole that I don't feel
necessarily serves me well justing so
you reach a place where you're working
at a large law firm which very often is
insane hours also yeah high-stress
didn't help
right because you picked a career which
is like pushes you to the edge so what's
the is there a big moment is this is it
is there like a gradual waking it
happens was there a moment where there
was definitely a moment I think the sort
of defining bottom that I had was a
marriage that went awry and I talked
about in my book it's a long story and
kind of too long to get into the details
of it for purposes of this interview but
essentially I had a merit I had a
wedding that did not culminate in a
marriage ended on the honeymoon and it
was quite a dramatic event in my life
that shocked me to my core and I think
that was my bottom as an alcoholic but
it was such a painful moment for me that
I
you need to medicate myself with drugs
and alcohol for the better part of like
the next nine months before I was ready
to kind of deal with it and then it was
just I woke up one day and I was like
I've had enough I'm ready to go to rehab
and you know booked a flight and got a
bed at a treatment center in rural
Oregon and you know just somehow found
the wherewithal to board that plane and
that was the first step in changing my
the trajectory of my life forever
whoa what say you a residential that for
a month or something like that actually
well I showed up thinking I'm just gonna
spend right here for a couple of weeks
and get back to my job
that was my plan right and the
counselors there once they you know I
was able to get to a place where I was
able to be honest with them about what I
was doing
and they kind of looked at me and said
yeah you know I think you might want to
stick around a little bit longer they
essentially said you have a your
alcoholism alcoholism is is sort of
progressed to the point of a 65 year old
man and we think you should stick around
and I could have said no nobody was
forcing me to be there but I ended up
staying for a hundred days so is there
for quite a long time and it really was
a process of rewiring my my mind body
and spirit completely and learning new
tools for living that so where do you go
from there because I mean you're
licensed you're skilled you could go
back in this profession and the same
pace of life in the same things but
right well I actually did when I got out
of the treatment facility I did go back
to the law firm they had been my boss
had been actually very supportive of of
this move and and I felt that the right
thing to do was to go back even if I
didn't want to and I knew that life was
not right for me to go back and kind of
honor the commitment they made to me by
by going and working there for at least
as long as I had been gone and and
really and so I did that until I reached
a point where I realized this was not
right for me and I ended up leaving and
starting my own
private-like sir boutique entertainment
transactional practice and pursued that
for the next number of years and really
kind of getting out of rehab and
embarking on this new life that really
was monopolized by recovery and creating
a foundation of sobriety I was able to
get back all of those things in my life
that I had lost I was able to repair the
relationships with my friends and my
family I was able to show up and be a
responsible member of society to be a
worker among workers to be honest to
look people in the eye and all these
things that had been challenges for me
when I was active in my alcoholism but
the one thing that I did not attend to
was my health with Fitness and you know
I had gained 50 pounds and was a very
very unfit by the time I was about 39
years old
oh yeah which for high stress a lot of
hours attorney almost no matter where
you are I mean I've lived that a much
shorter amount of time and I remember I
was I was a disaster
physically health i'm ended up in the
hospital I was an emergency surgery
wagon as I was on a deal and we worked
like the better part of three weeks
without sleeping and I was in horrible
pain for the last few days and I had a
raging infection in the middle of my
body that literally ate a hole through
my intestine from the outside edge so we
literally hit the button on the deal and
I went to the hospital and they like was
wheeled into emergency surgery but I
think so many extreme examples I think
so many people not just in law I think
law is particularly sort of acceptable
to people just completely tuning out the
visceral signals that their body is
giving them absolutely and while also
there's a culture in that environment
that that is supportive of that
lifestyle you know and there's a kind of
weird false pride that goes along with
that like what you're not eating dinner
at the law firm like what are you doing
that are you weak and I remember one
incident in my firm where I was it on a
Saturday morning or Sunday morning quite
early and there was a guy who was on the
cusp of being named partner
who was working on a summary judgment
motion and his his wife had just given
birth like hours prior along I was in
the he was in the law firm like cranking
out this brief when I was like why
aren't you at the hospital with your
wife and your babies how to get this
done you know and that was one in many
moments where I thought yeah this is not
this this is not a good law something's
not right yeah so yeah and edit Leigh
said I don't mean to slam law but it is
one of probably a number of professions
where you know like because a lot of the
times we work with Investment Banking
also it's built around a culture of you
know like if you're not suffering if
you're not feeling the same amount of
pain as everybody else around us you're
not sort of like 100 miles an hour right
you're not really practicing now
remember like one day being in an office
and I think I was leaving around 6:00 at
night and like that and somebody walking
by and say ah half day huh yeah exactly
like okay that's how it is so so what do
you do about it
so what happened in my case was on the
eve of my 40th birthday I'd been up late
I got home late from work and I stayed
up late watching television after my
family was asleep and I think it was
eating a bag of jack-in-the-box
cheeseburgers I had like what you call
my friend of my calls the window diet if
you can roll down the window and
somebody hands it to you you eat it and
that's kind of how I how I was
subsisting at the time and you know it
was time to go to bed was walking up the
stairs and about halfway up the
staircase like I had to stop like I was
out of breath I was buckled over sweat
on my brow tightness in my chest and it
scared me I thought that I was on the
precipice of having a heart attack and I
thought you know I'm 39 like I had to
take a break walking up a simple flight
of stairs
you know I need to do something about
this and I think this is kind of where
the sobriety story plays into what
happened next because when I made that
decision to get sober and
on that airplane and go to that rehab it
was like a little crack on the door you
know the door cracked open and I had a
choice like you're going to walk through
this door but if you don't do it right
away like I've had I just decided I was
going to do it that day I might have
never done it you know sort of that the
preciousness of those little moments of
opportunity and you're going to act and
your life is going to change or if you
don't like you may not get that sort of
moment again and so when I had that
staircase episode I was able to
recognize that this was once again one
of those moments that was important and
I needed to do something right away if I
just blew it off and you know kind of
perpetuated my denial about my scenario
you know I don't know that I would have
ever made any change but so at this
point you also you have a family so it's
not just you that you're making
decisions for and it's not just you that
this would be impacting yeah absolutely
I have two teenage step sons and two
daughters the youngest of which had not
been born at this point but yeah I was
scared for myself and I was you know I
wasn't the head of a family it was
terrifying and I have my I have a
grandfather my mother's father who had
been a champion swimmer in college was
captaining the University of Michigan
swim team and an Olympic hopeful an
American record holder who had remained
healthy his whole life and and had been
you know a swimmer his whole life never
overweight never smoked and died of a
heart attack at in his early 50s died
long before before I was born of course
so my mother would always say we've got
to watch out about your health and heart
disease runs in our family and you know
here was a guy who in many ways is my
doppelganger is you know I was named
after him and he loved swimming like I
did and and that kind of you know I
thought about that a lot in that moment
thinking you know if I don't make a
change I'm headed in the same direction
as this guy probably sooner based upon
how I feel right now and so what I did
what the first thing I did I wish I
could tell you I went to the library and
got a bunch of books and watched a bunch
of documentaries and said this is how to
be healthy I didn't do that I wish I had
it would have saved a lot of time but my
wife is a always been much healthier
than I at a video go practice in ER into
all sorts of you know Eastern healing
modalities and and that was always kind
of like her thing you know and if you
were to look in her in our fridge it was
pretty clear like the food she was
eating in the food I was eating right um
like zoned off exactly skull and
crossbones exactly and I'm like that's
great for you honey I love you but you
know I mean it does and but I was you
know I was desperate and the next day I
said hey you know that that juice
cleanse you did you know six or eight
months ago like I think I want to try
that and she looked at me like confused
of that you know who I like yeah like
what she does if I said you know the
high heels in the in the closet I want
to wear those today you know like it was
so out of character for me I'm you know
it was the last person who would
entertain doing something weird like
that I liked toxin remove toxins what
toxins you know I'm the logic based guy
and you know I understand science and
you know I know best I went to Stanford
and you know that sort of thing but it
was it was a I was in a place where I
was ready to suspend my preconceived
notions about what I thought was right
or my way and again that's very similar
to a cornerstone principle of recovery
it's sort of being willing to ask for
help being willing willing to entertain
the notion that you know your way might
not be the best way and so I did that I
did a seven-day fruit and vegetable
juice cleanse so what was that I'm
curious though I mean at first the new
wife's got the out surprise chopped rare
you know aliens have taken my husband
yes but was there was there any tension
I mean it because it's it's so
interesting to me if you have two people
who are in relation who love each other
you're building a family together but
generally if one person is sort of like
a real zealot about like the health and
lifestyle it's it's a big part of them
and then if you have one person who's
your partner in life
who's the complete opposite was that
something that caused ongoing tension it
was just kind of an accepted thing it's
a great question
and and the answer is interesting you
know I think for a certain number of
years she what she would like encourage
me like hey you should you should you
know look at this this way or me here's
a book you should read and she put books
on my book stand and I wouldn't open
them and I wouldn't read them and I
think that that definitely caused her
some frustration and consternation but
she's also far more enlightened than I
and she understands a key kind of
spiritual principle which is
non-attachment
well and she made a decision after sort
of pursuing things that way and
realizing that I wasn't biting or wasn't
changing to let go like she said I love
you exactly the way you are I'm not
attached to you changing and kind of you
know resolved it was resolved to that
and it's when she made that decision to
kind of let go and just appreciate me
for who I was that I started to change
it's a very interesting you know sort of
spiritual equation somewhere in there
you know of letting go and allowing the
person their space and then you know
maybe something subconsciously in me was
reacting to that like hey why isn't she
pushing me to read all these books
anymore and then it was on me that I
know it came down to personal
responsibility like I needed to want it
for myself not because she wanted me to
do it hmm
yeah I mean that's big um so so you
decided to actually say okay let's do
this mm-hmm and at that point what did
she become attached again no actually it
was like I had to say you know let's get
the stuff like I'm ready to go and she
was like yeah yeah like I don't think
she believed me right I took her I had
to ask her like three times before she
actually went to the store with me to
get that stuff because she was like she
really was not attached and she maybe
she didn't believe that I was serious I
don't know it's funny how that how that
played out but yeah I I did it and the
first couple days I remember being
buckled over on the couch and I felt
like I was back in rehab detoxing and
you know weathering a detox is something
I was familiar with it was sort of you
know
I know how this feels and I know that it
will change like if I can just get
through the next couple days it'll start
to shift and that's what happened it's
kind of interesting then the fact that
you had had really the detox experience
from like drugs and alcohol gave you the
understanding what the process would
rate and that you would actually come
out the other side this was actually
okay to be it was not great place yeah
there was an extreme amount of
discomfort or a couple days but you know
I was like okay I know I know what
there's almost like okay bring it on you
know ready for this like let me let me
weather this well and it did shift you
know day three I felt better day for
starting to feel really good you know
the last couple days of the Klan's I
experienced a resurgence and vitality
and energy levels that I couldn't ever
remember having and it was profound you
know it really hammered home this idea
that that food is medicine indeed that
we do have the power to heal ourselves
and and the fact that I could have
abused my body for so long with drugs
and alcohol and terrible diet and then
in a mere seven days feel great well is
you know a testament to the resilience
of the human body when you treat it
right that so that becomes a springboard
I guess sure yeah sure so then of course
being a good alcoholic I'm like well I'm
just going to drink juice for the rest
of my life I'm never to go back to food
you know but of course you got to start
eating again and I thought well what am
I going to do now like I feel so good I
want to keep feeling this good and once
again I wish that I'd gotten a bunch of
books on the subject and set myself on a
proper trajectory again it everything
goes back to recovery for me and in
recovery they teach you that you're
either using drugs or you're sober
you're either drinking or you're not
there's a very black-and-white sort of
calculus to the whole thing and so I
think vegetarian is an appeal to me from
a health perspective because it's black
and white I could wrap my brain around
it's like oh you're immediate you're not
eating me
I understand that yeah that's like a
language that that makes sense to me
but I can I can I can grapple with that
and so I tried it I tried a 100% whole
food plant-based diet really thinking
this isn't going to work either but at
least I can say I've exploited all that
avenues and that's where you know I
experienced literally nothing short of a
miracle I mean it was again within seven
days of making that switch I felt like I
did on the latter days of that juice
cleanse and I felt amazing
and that's when I knew I was onto
something and then I began to educate
myself so that was sort of the beginning
of my journey towards you know returning
to athleticism right and at that point
had you started assuming when you were
sort of like working crazy hours that
exercise was wasn't a part of your life
right no not at all
so this does the change in food and this
whole thing also coincide with you
starting to move your body more yeah
absolutely
I don't think that I would have returned
to exercising again had I not changed my
diet I mean the diet comes first and I
had so much energy all of a sudden that
I need I just needed an outlet for it I
was bouncing off the walls literally
like I need to do something with my with
myself and it wasn't
I had no designs on returning to being a
competitive athlete I just I wanted to
lose my gut you know and I wanted to be
able to enjoy my children at their
energy level and that was really my
aspiration yeah on a pair of running
shoes my wife bought me a bike for my
40th birthday and you know I started
jumping in the pool once in a while and
going on a casual bike ride on a
Saturday afternoon with some friends
certainly nothing competitive it was
really just again burning off this out
of energy and and then in reconnecting
with a part of myself that I feel like I
had lost of the youth you know how much
I love swimming how much I love being
outdoors and pushing my body so it
really started something which was I
mean it wasn't a concerted effort to
compete or become great at something was
just not at all you were vibrating he
needed a way dissipate the energy it was
like yeah I was I was vibrating I was
taking in a different vibration and my
body was responding to that vibration by
directing me on a new path right so how
do you make the jump from just burning
off the extra energy that you have to
being this extreme athlete and a lot of
people's minds that's a pretty huge jump
yeah and it didn't you know it seems
like it happened overnight it was over
the course of you know maybe a year and
a half I suppose it started ice it first
started when maybe four months or so
into this kind of dietary experiment and
this you know resurgence of kind of
feeling my body again I went out for a
morning run it was a weekday morning my
plan was just to run for 45 minutes or
an hour on a local trail and was one of
those days where everything just felt
great like anybody who's a runner knows
this or athlete and everything just
clicks and you feel bullet bridge just
go for it just go and and that's what I
did I just kept going and going and
going and till I realized I'd been
running almost two hours away from my
car where I'd parked at the base of the
trail I didn't have any water with me
and I was like what are you doing I was
like I feel so good but like this is
really you're responsible I could like
collapse and then on this trail in the
middle Miller turned around and ran back
and felt you know great all the way to
the end and ended up running like almost
you know the better part of a marathon
that morning like a blue you know just
and I thought what is going on you know
either I've unlocked some dormant gene
or this you know this diet is working
for me in a way that I could not have
imagined or you know I don't know what
but I felt like directed to exploring
this part of who I was and in a new way
and that kind of led me to thinking
about a challenge and you know and sort
of exploring further that question of
how resilient is the human body and you
know having come from a place of abusing
it for so long
what is it capable of now like at age 40
to 43 I wanted to answer that question
for myself and since either already
essentially just run run a marathon
right was the victim it wasn't it and it
didn't feel like any big deal so I
thought well what if I could do that
like what would happen if I actually
prepared for something you know in a
away and set my sights on a goal and I
thought well you know I can I can enter
this marathon or maybe I'll do an
Ironman and just nothing really clicked
as being super you know as giving me
that like feeling that you know of being
inspired yeah and then I and then I read
an article about this race called
Ultraman which I'd never heard of which
is you know people most people know what
an Ironman is but if you don't an
Ironman is a is a very long triathlon
race which during the course of one day
you swim 2.4 miles you bike 112 miles
and then you run a marathon yeah and
this Ultraman race is essentially a
little bit more than double that and
over the course of three days you
circumnavigate the entire Big Island of
Hawaii which is like roughly the size of
Connecticut some big island and the
first day you swim 6.2 miles and then
you ride your bike 90 miles the second
day you ride your bike 170 miles and the
third day you run 50 2.4 miles a double
marathon Wow
and I was reading this article about
this race that I'd never heard of that
apparently had been around for 25 years
there's no media coverage there's no
money there's no prize money there's
nothing it's sort of a very grassroots
kind of a vet that is probably what
Ironman was like back in 1980 I want to
started all right and there was
something about that that I found really
appealing and in the description of this
race it made it sound like this
spiritual Odyssey there are only 35
athletes that are invitation-only from
all over the world they're invited and
compete in this race
everybody has to bring their own crew a
vehicle like a van that drives with each
athlete to make sure they get from place
to place and there's this in why they
call it Ohana it's the spirit of family
where every athlete and their crew is
making sure that all the other athletes
are attended to and the idea is that
everybody crosses the finish line and of
course it's a race and there's people
that want to win but it was really that
this kind of core kind of communalism
about this race that real
captured my imagination and was one of
those things in life where you see
something and I switch flicks and you're
like well I'm going in this direction
you know it made no sense logically that
I would be any in any position to
participate in this event but there was
something inside of me that knew that I
was going to be doing that race well so
you just went all-in I did I you know I
read that article and I couldn't stop
thinking about it for a couple days is
crazy as it sounded and I called up the
race director it was some months before
this race was open to receiving
applications called her up and I said I
just read this article about this race
and I'm really interested in it at night
and I want to do it and she said well
what have you done yeah existed this
really what are they eating
cheeseburgers on the couch for a long
time I was like I haven't done anything
and she should have said well why don't
you run a couple marathons or do an
Ironman and call me in a year or two and
we'll talk but she didn't say that what
she said was well it's it's interesting
that you called and that you're
expressing this interest and there's a
little bit of time and why don't you
check in with me in another couple
months and we'll see where you're at
well because it was a it was a really I
was only 35 people only 35 people and
the races gained considerable popularity
over the last couple years so at this
time you know this was prior to the 2008
race there was a little more flexibility
and being accepted to compete right but
it was another prep another crack in the
door you noticed I've you know continued
the theme where she gave me a little
glimmer of hope and I and I grabbed onto
that and I knew that if I took the
opportunity seriously and kind of walked
through that door that there was a good
chance that I would be able to line up
the starting line for that race and so I
proceeded accordingly
you know I hired a coach and got a
training program together and
had about six or seven months to get
ready for this race which isn't a lot of
time for me oh I haven't been doing my
athletic yeah yeah yeah I mean the
ironman alone is something that people
trained for of course yeah huge amount
and very often after years of working up
to it absolutely so to do double that is
pretty tremendous so so eventually I'm
assuming you call her back and she says
yeah exactly so I stayed in touch with
her and eventually wore her down and
office I said okay okay I'll let you in
right I said thank you I will not
disappoint you and and I and I trained
you know really hard because I didn't
want to you know that meant a lot to me
that she showed me you know that she
showed some faith in me I was taking a
leap of faith and I wanted to honor that
by making sure that I was as physically
and mentally prepared for that race as I
could be in a short period of time they
which is tricky because you can't rap if
you ramp up your volume too quickly for
something like that in your training
you're going to get injured or over
trained yeah I mean which is the other
the flipside I was thinking you like
because it's so extreme you know you get
concerned about going the opposite
direction of you know that you become
now addicted to this other thing which
actually destroys your body but in a
different way right yeah and I get that
question a lot like haven't you just
transferred your all of your you know
addictive behavior on to this extreme
sports template and and you know it's a
it's a valid question you know and it's
something that I that I have to soul
search over and I certainly think that
that you know this the extreme nature of
ultra endurance sports is a perfect sort
of vehicle for an addict because there's
no end to the amount of obsessive you
know kind of training that you can pour
into it and I have to be careful about
that
I mean I would imagine that that's part
of the allure for me but at the same
time you know I have so many other
things I'm doing in my life you know
and husband and father of children and
so for me you know balance is the thing
that I'm always trying to focus on like
how can I pursue this thing that for
whatever reason I'm attracted to and
still maintain balance in my life
because if my relationship with my wife
gets derailed or I'm not seeing my kids
like what is the point of all of this
you know so I always you know I'm always
kind of making lists making sure that my
priorities are in check mmm it sounds
like also to a certain extent I mean the
level of competition that you're doing
is it becomes a metaphor for other
things mm-hmm yeah absolutely
I mean I think that that on some level I
believe that you know I'm kind of meant
to pursue the sport I certainly have a
you know an acuity for it and I'm a
happier person when I'm doing it and I
feel that I'm more fully expressed and
actualized when on when I'm doing it to
the extent that when I'm not training my
wife will say we please go ride your
bike you're much better person I like
you more when you're yeah and yeah it's
it's a metaphor not everyone is going to
want to go out and and race Ultraman or
or you know participate in extreme
sports but for me I feel it is kind of
the manifestation of this journey
towards reconnecting with myself and and
being able to kind of express more fully
Who I am and be comfortable with that
in my own skin yeah that's powerful to
find something like that that allows you
that maybe life I think so many people
are looking for it like the thing that
lets you be so fully expressed that it's
just you know it's almost like it
becomes a part of you you know yeah I
mean I you know Henry David Thoreau said
the mass of men lead lives of quiet
desperation and
it was true that and I think it's just
as true if not more true I know and you
know I relate to that a lot and I think
about that quote a lot and I certainly
live that life for a long time and it's
been a hard rot journey to kind of
figure out you know how do was you know
some escape path out of that and I feel
very fortunate and I'm very grateful
that I found that but I am also very
empathetic to people and in particularly
men who struggle with this because you
know life is difficult then you got to
put food on the table and all these
sorts of real life issues that we have
like I don't have time to figure out
what makes me happy because I'm so busy
in the day-to-day of my life but I think
that we all have dreams defer that are
locked inside of us and we all have like
a more authentic version of ourselves
that's yearning to come out and I think
you know the the natural healthy state
of man is to be more expressed in that
well that's powerful
I completely agree you've done it I'm on
the road hmm yeah I mean I wouldn't say
I'm but yeah I mean it's a struggle it
is I mean to me one of the biggest sort
of awakenings is that there is no there
there mm-hmm
you know it's kind of like it's just
it's funny like what people always asked
me because I was ask them you know like
you know like art you know can you live
a good life if you don't know or if
you're not at that place you know where
you feel like okay I'm finally living a
good life and one of my big awakenings
through a lot of these conversations and
just introspection and living and doing
things is that it's it's not a place
that you get to it's a lens that you
bring to where you are and you know like
the moment you decide you know it's it's
that's what it's about because there is
no place that you get to write you know
it's disappointing to hear that and yet
you know but that's that's the reality
you know not a true I mean it's
disappointing but it but in a certain
way also empowering because really like
you know what that means that I can
actually flip the switch right now today
I just need to I need to figure out now
I need to explore different set of tools
that allow me to figure out how do I
swap a different lens now
for me the most powerful tools are
practicing gratitude which is not my
natural default state by any means and
it requires a lot of focus on my part
and attention in order to get to that
place and being of service and when I'm
in gratitude when I'm in service then my
life is good and other people's lives
are better today right good kind of guy
was going to wrap up saying yes this is
a good luck project in your mind if I
asked you what does it mean to live a
good life that's part of it being in
gratitude being in being of service and
being connected with yourself in a way
that allows you to be fully expressed as
your unique self I like that yeah so so
enjoy getting to know a lot more about
you and your journey and thank you for
the conversation yeah thanks for having
me it's great to be here yeah my
pleasure so cool and I'm Jonathon fields
my guest today has been rich role
signing off for a good life front